Comcast introducing expanded universe
logo jinxes expanded universe before the
first movie in the universe even starts
reading movie just whipped it's lengthy
logos out three seconds ago and then
forces us to stare at him again this is
clearly textual harassment some guy puts
the Blood Diamond in a thing and I'm
supposed to be all happy because he's
wearing a backpack present-day is the
cop out of titles what does it even mean
when the movie was shot when it was
released if I watch it in 20 years will
it still be present-day movies like my
wife scheduling our date night
just pick a time would you but today an
ancient - filled with the coffins of
Crusader Night exposition by news
broadcast the past cannot remain buried
forever now we have narration so reading
exposition by news broadcast
then narration all inside five minutes
this movie is intentionally trying to
trigger me and you know what it just
might work
incest Amin it can't even a little bit
of this information don't be handed to
the audience later The Mummy wakes up
goes off kills fools then we start
learning bits and pieces of all this
would that be better set the god of
death they made a pact you could set
this Russell Crowe narration over shots
from the first third of Noah and I
probably wouldn't be able to tell the
difference quadruple pupil I'll
certainly know it looks cool but exactly
how would quadruple pupil function seems
to me suddenly having to process extra
visual information would at least take
some getting used to
Dardis ex machina for her sins are
Manette was mummified did they really
leave eye holes and mummies this looks
more like a speedy paper machine
Halloween costume than a true
mummification also he has now been
exposing aerating for three and a half
minutes straight I timed it adding 50
freakin sins for this movie's exposition
explosion there she would remain
condemned to eternal darkness so the
parallax during that always works
exactly is going on here
target practice if so what does this guy
with the hammer doing are they really
attempting statue demolition be a
gunfighter also isn't this guy directly
in the line of fire well that's gonna be
Tom Cruise for sure but I do secretly
wish it was a job or even Robin Williams
from Fisher King anything to make this
movie slightly less predictable with
regard Henry does this mean Harrison
Ford will show up is someone gonna get
shot in the head develop amnesia and
forget this movie ever happen can I
volunteer here we have another overused
troupe where a character repeatedly
insists there
going to do a thing when there's no
doubt in anyone's mind they're going to
ultimately do the thing thanks for
wasting our time moving somehow this air
strike they called in arrives in like 30
seconds and does not injure or kill
either of our two heroes building
surfing also how much you want to bet
this collapse brought on by the
airstrike explosion actually opens up
some two more exposes some kind of
ancient bullsh required to advance the
plot what 500 bucks rom pay up how did
anyone at the studio sign off on 55 year
old Tom Cruise playing some active
special ops field agent with a penchant
for screwing up even Josh Cuomo is tool
flesh you hunt for antiquities stealing
whatever isn't nailed down and selling
it on the black market if you know this
why do you keep sending them out I guess
you're gonna punish him now so the movie
has some manufactured tension but if
this is his reputation and you haven't
punished him so far and he's 55 goddamn
years old you have only yourself to
blame you're getting in the hole women
wait what I'm with blue scarf lady on
this how does this make any sense to
send these two down with her you just
said you don't trust them and now you're
gonna send them down with her alone
I'm so mad at you I'm going to give you
direct access to the very thing you came
here for this whole thing opened up
because of an airstrike in a building
collapse but no one involved here seems
the least bit concerned that even more
ground around the hole might give way
waned in reality the camera here is so
huge the entire town should have been
sucked into a sinkhole get the lights
and seven hours later after they somehow
lure all this down into the cavern and
then fed power to it as well the lights
came on the most beautiful way to set up
lights for a movie shot is also the
least practical in real life remind me
again why we set up the lights a hundred
feet away from the space we actually
want illuminated digital cameras did not
do this floating invisible camera
floating invisible camera is now
handheld magically appearing previously
floating an invisible handheld camera
also what is she even looking at to know
what she's shooting movie absolutely has
no idea how to camera as this treasure
is stolen it's as good a time as any to
bring up the choice not to have anyone
else down here weird enough you sent
down the idiots and thieves you don't
trust but then you don't send down any
security or manpower to keep them in
check
surprise actually I think it might be
both man so was this movie you say that
but clearly that getting out now part of
your order is going to take 45 minutes
based on what we were shown when they
were lowered down and by then any bogeys
will be full-on bogie he shoots the rope
and activates the ancient thing out of
the blue after being ordered out of
there because why are you because the
mummy has to show up in this movie at
some point and a screenwriter couldn't
find a way for it to happen that made
any sense so he wrote this yes we buried
her for her terribleness but we created
a Goonies booby trap to bring her back
up just in case in the future they want
to make movies about this mummy movie
that needs a cheap scare goes for sudden
spiders with somewhat hilarious results
do your title maker if you're going to
make us read the least you could do is
not make the font skinny small in the
same color as the freaking sand do it
movie embarks on a two-hour effort to
make its female leave both unlikable and
unnecessary meaning she doesn't need to
be here and we don't want her here yet
she shall remain not only is this the
second mummy movie to feature a sudden
sandstorm it's the second Tom Cruise
movie to feature a southern sandstorm it
is not movie took way too many notes
from Jurassic world on how to write
characters with a romantic past to
create cliche sexual tension let's go
over the facts here just stab someone
twice he's not responding to your voice
he looks like a zombie he's walking
towards you just end him already what
I'll see you waiting for it's a murder
of crows oh wait those are Ravens aren't
they so it's a murder of Ravens also
known as a ray lewis special what to
film this scene for the sake of
authenticity you Tom Cruise actually
strapped himself into a plane and
crashed it on purpose we need your help
identifying the bodies you do because
this unnecessary bull spear slinging
here
she literally met these dude today sure
mystical resurrection blah blah blah how
has nobody been freaking out that his
body is even still intact fun visual I
guess but how would he be unknown he was
on a flight with such sensitive artifact
material his name and rank would have
been logged in about half a dozen
different places but whatever movie
let's just be honest you lost me at
hello
you know what's happening exposition
comic relief zombie goes suck said
exposition
this is what should happen to anyone
that tries using the you better come
take a look at this cliche also couldn't
the movie just started here with the
first mummy attacked it be more
mysterious and literal
everything we've learned up till now
could easily have been given to us via
dialog flashbacks and natural story
progression does the mummy lady actually
mean to kiss her victims on the lips or
she just warning I guess whoever she
moment finds actually turns into a
zombie
and not a mummy I suppose that makes it
easier for the movie to give our heroes
some drone bad he used to kill later in
the finale
it still doesn't jive with much of mummy
lore did you cut out of that plan
there's not a single scratch funny
unbreakable remake is a lot more mummy
centric than I remember the original
being we've developed this theory that
an Egyptian princess had been erased
from the history books you've developed
a theory out of thin air then the dagger
sent a ceremonial knife with a large
jewel at the hilt this movie is like a
pubescent boy I can't get enough of its
own expositor and ends up rubbing itself
wrong you've angered the gods yep set
Thor Hades Jehovah jay-z they're all
pissed at you you know I always thought
I had a chance for their what
expositional comic relief zombie ghost
also sucks at Comic Relief look at me
look at my face I'm cursed Nick pickle a
movie Boris or brenden most of the movie
wants to karlof it up this character
feels like he should be hanging out with
bridger she's got plans for you man
can't run you can't escape even if this
is true why didn't she just show up to
Nick herself and explain why use the
dead not funny friend guy as a conduit
especially when she's going to show
herself to him in the alley in the next
scene
why are rats attacking him was she
controlling them do you care does it
matter
is it creepy okay I guess kissing is the
official kill you but come back to life
and I control you mechanism in this film
ancient Egyptian curses are weirdly
obsessed with what is a relatively
modern romantic custom
I swear to God at this movie flashes
back to the same desert scene one more
time
I may have to shove its obelisk so far
up its sarcophagus you won't even be
able to read the hieroglyphs Terry Tate
mummy linebacker
why is she surprised she obviously can
sense where these artifacts are but
somehow she didn't know that the stone
was missing instead of completing the
ritual the mummy lady goes after Ginny
who I'm guessing poses exactly 1.5% of a
true problem creature who has previously
quickly and efficiently sucked the life
out of every non cruse human in her path
decided to throw her across the room
instead because reasons Tom Cruise in
World War Z Nick takes off without Jenny
which is sexist logical predictable and
hilarious you're saying that she brought
the plane down there on purpose yeah and
with such pinpoint accuracy I'm guessing
she must be working with the gal from
hidden figures Nick she's in your head
imagine if Dumbledore had been this
direct with Harry we'd have never gotten
order of the Phoenix this stuff with the
attacking mummy zombie torso goes on for
some time for the second time in this
movie Tom Cruise falls out of a vehicle
crash that he will miraculously survive
Oh No here she comes slowly walking
through the woods
why don't were villains always a quick
deliberate walking with terror what's
more hilarious and grabbing this stick
or Jenny yelling get her Nick it's a tie
in my book
black ops saviors repeatedly shoot the
mummy with darts and arrows which means
there's some kind of whale incorporation
keep the evil alive for research going
down right now
else they'd be firing Hellfire missiles
and RPGs at our ass HAARP 106 machina
collector of rare monster artifacts puts
them on display where they can be seen
stolen or accidentally destroyed by
anyone walking through oh snap
remember how Russell Crowe was in this
and spent eight minutes narrating the
opening yeah me neither
chuckle shameless dark universe building
attempted shameless if he knows how
dangerous he is when he turns why on
earth will you wait to be this close
before giving himself his height a BB
shot in truth few months for us
Ginny betrayal is the worst kind of
betrayal also remember how Russell Crowe
was in this and spent eight minutes
narrating the opening yeah me neither
but how our mere earthly chains keeping
this ancient God chick confined if
handcuffs were enough to subdue her why
did the Egyptians barrier so far
underground inside a stone sarcophagus
how the humans even you know what forget
the I honestly don't care a pony I love
my father with all my heart
sheesh I can understand the need for a
bit of exposition to catch us up
but we've already heard and seen this
story twice before and once through
narration I will not be xxx position
damn it and that's why you use
protection
always make sure your mummy Junior is
wrapped securely before burial kids what
was I supposed to tell you would you
even have believed me
Tom Cruise's agent after she convinced
him to say yes to this film and
immediately after he'd read the script
despite my better judgment I care about
you movie tries to get us to buy into a
relationship between two characters with
so little chemistry not even Walter
White could find it drink dear god yes
please you language is simple only a
fictional movie character whatever saved
this about the English language because
English is stuff y'all but also and
perhaps more importantly after one third
of the movie being backstory and one
third with her chained up I'm beginning
to think this mummy movie has very
little interest in mummy
thank God this building had a museum
quality advancement of humanoid skulls
display so that Nick would be distracted
by it so that Jekyll could surprise him
with some kind of a struggling to
pretend like a care any more on this one
Chris just FYI when writing a narration
is gonna get less and less inspired as
we move forward she's talking to a
spider a spider I'm truly sorry mr.
Morton studio is so committed to this
Dirk universe bull they have to
literally cram in some mr. Hyde into the
movie where we're first meeting dr.
Jekyll you have brain controlled spiders
in your arsenal with a couple easy
incantations and you're just now using
one high-tech fastly important door
security system has one door on a delay
because you never know when you'll need
a convenient plot point King who even
when your character is puking liquid
metal I still don't need to see
characters puking and movies goddammit
movie includes cursed book from the 1999
mummy film does this mean those movies
are in the same world as this one this
expanded universe just got expanding
here yeah good thing she ran through
that door beat that guy up so she could
do absolutely nothing
seriously this movie has no idea how to
use this character I live in some
knowledge exposition exactly what has
she done
she didn't even pull her own parachute
cord in the plane crash for pete's sake
[Music]
okay that was some badass mummy circus
Elena's right there
and I take us in off if it weren't for
the fact that the rig is needlessly
complex just so it could happen what can
I say the boy likes to run in his movies
with this much power what exactly does
she need him for again she just lonely
codependent honey you don't need a man
to make you home you good girl but also
you're dead and you haven't been seen in
an hour I'm really thinking you're just
part of the evil chicks plant what's up
how did he know she was about to be
attacked
how was he remotely close enough to save
her house screw it man like I give it
movie can't decide if it's zombie
mummy's are slow and one at a time or
fast and all at once can't just World
War Z it when it suits you movie keep
your zombies consistent oh she's a
murmur me now too had he not trained so
hard to hold his breath from Mission
Impossible rogue nation Tom Cruise would
definitely have died shooting this
stupid underwater scene for the stupid
mummy movie wait why are these Knights
of the Dead table disintegrating why
isn't Nick running right now if Nick had
this little control over things why did
I even watch this movie eh
Jesus mommy lady why is his submission
so important to you you imprinted on him
early on presumably you do not need the
human inside him to get permission and
yet you keep asking for it drawing off
the film's runtime okay I'm calling a
family meeting let's count the ways this
moment ruins the last shred of hope for
this film first other than a false
surprise is there really any reason he
needs to stab himself nothing has been
mentioned about the knife giving the
stabber the power over the stabby so who
cares who does the penetrating to he has
absolutely no idea what the stabbing
will do except turn him into the
definition of evil so why does he even
think this would bring his passive and
pointless lady friend back to life three
did you see that knife it was dull from
age and curved it might bruise a sternum
but it ain't stabbing anything
Oh what's up yo all he had to do was
crush the red stone the mummy lady even
said so but instead he stabs himself
with the Ruby blade that mummy lady has
been hoping to stab him with all movie
movie gives us a visual summary of what
it's been doing to us for the last 90
minutes somehow he got so attached to
Ginny during this film he literally
cannot live without her like the most
for scum thing about this movie I guess
demon cruise is evil book does good
sorry mummy you can't go both ways is
the mercury still necessary her life has
been sucked out the stone is shattered
and jolly Satan Nick pretty much decides
who
lives or dies now anyway what are we
even doing here veil would be great at
cinemasins yes those I don't know what
they are you don't know what they are
who gives a shit this Fred
[Music]
get the lights
[Applause]
[Music]